- What's up Believe Nation?
Happy Weekend!
I thought it was time to make version two
of How to Hit a Million Subscribers.
I made my first video on this in February.
At that time, I had, how many did I have,
569,000 subscribers.
I'm not sitting at 639,000 subscribers.
So that's a 70,000 subscriber swing.
Getting a little bit closer to 1 million,
and I wanted to share with you my journey,
and as well, teach you
lesson that I've learned
to help you get your YouTube
goals accomplished faster.
Last time, I talked about my
channel versus Eric Thomas.
He was a guy who I considered to be
one of the best speakers
of our generation,
somebody who I look up
to as a great speaker,
someone who I consider, in a way,
better than me at speaking,
and he's having great results
in the speaking world,
but I'm beating him on YouTube because
I'm playing better to
the YouTube algorithm,
and the lesson last time was
you need to upload frequently.
I was uploading multiple times per day,
and he was uploading once a week
or a couple of times a week.
I forget exactly how much,
but the frequency was way lower compared
to what I was doing, and
that's why I was winning.
There's a direct correlation between
the number of videos that I was posting
with the growth of my channel.
Now, you have to post good stuff.
You can't post crap.
It's got to be something that people enjoy
and we're really meticulous
about eliminating series
that aren't performing well,
and I'll probably get to
that in a future video
to help you guys break
down how to understand
if the series is working or not for you,
at least how we do it,
but if you're posting good stuff
and you're doing it frequently,
you're going to win
against people who are just
posting good stuff,
maybe even better stuff
very infrequently.
It just is how YouTube's algorithm works.
You may not agree with it,
you may not think it's right,
but it's how it is, and so
paying attention to the data
can allow you to win on
YouTube, where other people
may have a lot of other advantages
are going to be second place.
Today I want to talk about
me versus Gary Vaynerchuk.
Gary's been a friend of the
business for a number of years.
I had my first collaboration
with him back in 2010.
I made a line of famous
entrepreneur trading cards.
This is the first page of them.
My favorite entrepreneur is A.P. Giannini.
His is Vince McMahon, and I got a quote
from him on the back.
So I'm going to flip to the back page.
You can see, this one is mine,
and then here's Gary
down below, loving Vince.
I've had him interviewed on my channel.
We've done some collaborations,
and so I want to compare
my YouTube channel to his.
Now, if you pull up my
SocialBlade account,
compare my channel to his,
we can't go all the way back.
It's limited, but I passed
his channel in September 2015.
The data that we have here shows
just the beginning of the year, 2016.
He was always ahead of me.
I passed him September 2015,
and I was widening the gap,
and what's happened recently is Gary
is closing the gap on me.
He's catching up and he's
catching up in a hurry,
in a hurry, and why?
Why is Gary catching up in a hurry?
This is what's real interesting.
This is what I look at.
I want to look a the data, I
want to understand the points.
Has Gary gotten a lot better as a speaker?
Not really.
Gary is already playing
at such a high level,
and if you look at what
he was saying a year ago
and his delivery, his enthusiasm,
compared to what he's doing now,
it's the same level of
enthusiasm and energy
and excitement, same bravado.
He hasn't really improved
that much as a speaker,
again, because he was already playing at
such a high level, he's been
doing this for so many years
that one year to the next is not really
having a big impact.
Has his team gotten better?
Yeah.
Have they added more
production quality to it?
Yes.
Has he introduced different series?
The biggest difference maker though
is the quantity of uploads.
I was crushing Gary and
zoomed right past him
because I was producing
way more than he was
and now, he's catching
up with the quantity.
Let me share some stats with you.
February 2016, Gary had 18 videos.
He posted 18 videos in the month.
That's pretty good.
I'm posting three a day, but
he's posting three a month
in February 2016.
February 2017, 50.
He went from 18 videos
in February last year
to 50 videos February this year.
Let's fast forward to March.
March 2016 he had 19 videos,
still solid, 19 videos.
It's one every two days,
just over one every two days.
It's good quality, consistent
content, 19 videos.
March 2017, 60, 60 videos!
He's goes from 19 to 60 videos.
He's uploading two a day or more,
and that's why he's winning.
He has quality content
and he's playing better
to YouTube algorithm, and
now, he's going to past me.
You look at the curve, he's catching up,
and he's on the path to beat me,
and so, I'm going to be making
a video in a couple of months
saying Gary is ahead of me,
and I'm now not the number one
channel for entrepreneurs
out there in the world,
and I got to up my game.
It's great, like it forces
me to want to play better,
to create better content for you guys,
to add more hustle, energy
'cause everybody else,
like I passed Gary, there's
nobody else in the field
who's doing really well.
Now the game is on and I love it.
So I really strongly encourage you guys
to look at how often you
are posting your videos.
You look at Gary, who was
doing a good job last year
and posting 19, 18 videos a month,
that's pretty solid, but
when he moved to daily
and when he moved to twice a day,
that's when his channel
really started to explode
to the point where nobody is catching him.
So you want to do that in your industry.
I would definitely look
at whatever your schedule
is right now and at
least try to double it.
I would then try to look
at how do I get to a daily
schedule and then how
do I move beyond daily,
and it challenges you
to think how can I add
really amazing content 'cause
if the value is not there,
it's not going to help you.
If you're just throwing up crap,
It's got to be good quality stuff,
at least once a day, if
not multiple times a day,
and again, I'm not saying it's right,
it's just how YouTube is working,
and if you play to their algorithm,
you have a better chance
of getting subscribers,
getting noticed, getting your message out
and driving that into
your business as well.
Alright, next up, I want
to answer some questions
from you guys, questions that you asked
on last edition's version.
So if you have questions for next time,
leave it down below, and
I'll see what I can do.
First up, Relaxing Sleep Station,
"I enjoyed the video Evan.
"I feel you're very
respectful when talking
"about Eric Thomas and
showing how regular content
"is important for the algorithm.
"Hopefully it helps a lot
of people get motivated
"to make more content."
Yeah, this whole me versus somebody,
it's a fun thing.
I love Eric.
We've profiled him a couple of times.
It worked with his team.
Gary, I've done collaborations with.
The other people I'm going
to mention in the future
of this series, I have a
relationship with as well.
It's mad respect.
I love what Eric is doing.
I love what Gary's doing.
It's not that I am
better than them or not,
it's just showing that
they could be doing better,
they could be getting way better results
if they follow some of these things,
and even if they don't pay attention,
you could be doing better if
you follow some of these tips
and strategies on your
own YouTube channel.
Chris Commisso, "Yes,
please continue this series.
"Thank you."
Well, this is version two.
We'll see what happens
in the coming months.
I'm committed to doing it, I
think, until I hit a million.
We'll see, we'll see.
If you guys respond and you're liking it,
you leave comments,
you're engaging with it,
we'll continue to a million.
MommyZ, "Love this series.
"Evan, my question is how
do I make my YouTube channel
"more attractive without
the money to invest
"in things like a better camera
"or channel design initially?"
A better camera and channel
design have a tiny impact.
How do you make it better?
You, you get better.
That's it.
The biggest factor of my
own channel is still me.
If I want to go out and
now catch up to Gary,
who's starting to crush
me, I'm still ahead of him,
but he's going to pass me soon.
How do I beat him?
I need to get better,
me, I need to get better.
My message needs to be better.
I need to have more passion.
I need to provide more value
to audience, it's me.
You want to win, it's not the gear.
It's never the gear.
I'm filming this off of a Logitech web cam
that I bought at Best Buy.
You don't need to have amazing gear.
You need to have an amazing message,
you need to provide amazing
value to your audience.
So stop thinking that
it's your channel art
and stop thinking that it's your camera
and you get better at providing value
to your audience.
Next up, Andy Jug, "I think
I prefer to stay behind
"the camera and do animation
and voice over videos
"but that would hinder my
personal branding, wouldn't it?"
Do you want to build a personal brand?
I think people connect easier to a face,
to a person but if all you
want to do is be behind
the camera, you want to do
a little animated summary
of yourself, have a little
character of yourself
and use your voice, that
could become your brand.
It's harder to connect
to a cartoon character
than it is to an individual.
If you came on and told your
story, it'd be a lot easier,
but maybe building a personal
brand isn't the right
way to go for your company.
You could tell your story
through this animated character.
You can have a lot of success.
It's not about doing it
just the way that you
see other people doing it,
like Eric has a personal brand,
Gary has a personal brand,
I have a personal brand,
it doesn't mean that you need to go out
and build a personal brand.
There's lots of people
who have won on YouTube
without having to have a personal brand,
and so you're forcing
yourself to go out and do it,
you're not going to have a lot of success,
unless it's what you want.
If you want to build a personal brand,
it's a deep thing that
you want to go out and do,
then get better at it,
get more comfortable, practice, practice,
practice, practice, but if
that's not where you want to go
and what you want to do is
draw amazing animation videos
and you want to do voiceover narration,
then do that and tell
your stories through that.
The impact of the personal
brand won't be as strong.
So yeah, it'll hurt your personal brand,
but you're net, net
value will be much bigger
because you're doing
the thing that you love
instead of trying to do somebody else.
Urban Jim, "How can I be less preachy
"and more natural like you?
"I love your videos and has
influenced my channel a ton,
"God bless."
Just practice, Jim.
I am not naturally gifted at this.
It took me a lot of practice.
I've made 4,000 videos.
Like, you better get good at something
if you've done it 4,000 times,
and it's just about developing your style.
Practice, practice,
practice, practice, practice.
The quantity will lead to the quality.
The more you practice,
the more you get better,
the more you (mumbles).
I like watching different peoples' styles,
the way somebody presents something,
I maybe pick up a little bit
and I apply it in my next video
and see, hmm, did that fit,
that doesn't feel right.
If you don't like being preachy,
then try not being preachy.
Try to find people that have
given speeches or have done
something similar to
what you're trying to do
in a non-preachy way.
If you like how I do it,
you feel I'm natural,
it starts with me feeling natural.
I'm not here trying to impress you guys.
I'm not here trying to say
I'm better than anybody else.
I'm trying to provide value.
I care about this message
and if you feel comfortable
and you feel natural,
then you'll make videos
where it's natural and comfortable,
and that may mean taking
a number of takes.
Maybe you shoot the whole video and feel,
you know what, that was preachy,
I'm going to do it again.
That sucked again, I'm
going to do it again,
and the more you get into it,
the first time I find
at least when I was first starting out
the first time, I felt nervous,
and it wasn't my best performance.
Even now when I start doing my videos,
I'll always start doing the simple ones,
like the Top 10s where
I'm not saying much,
I'm just doing intro,
extra, that kind of stuff,
and it gets me warmed up and revved up.
You really do the (mumbles)
and the Believe Lives
and the videos where I
have to be more passionate
I got to be more thought, leadership.
Just practice, man.
Don't beat yourself up.
It's going to come if you put in the work.
Exist N Nature, "It's hard
to compare, people jump
"on and off when you're not consistent.
"He's creating a lot of
business for himself offline."
I think it's in reference
to Eric Thomas last time.
Absolutely, this series
is only about how to hit
a million subscribers.
It's not about how to build
a million-dollar business.
It's not about how to
funnel your people offline.
Eric Thomas' number one goal
was a million subscribers
on YouTube, then his
priories would be different.
Now, he's trying to
build his book business,
he's trying to build
his speaking business,
he's trying to build his apparel business.
He's got all these paths
that YouTube helps funnel,
but it's not the main thing for him.
So that's fine, and
this is the whole point,
it is hard to compare somebody
who is not consistent.
This is the message to you guys.
I want you to be consistent.
If hitting a subscriber goal is important
for you on YouTube, if you want
to have success on YouTube,
then you need to be consistent.
Otherwise, even if you're
great, like Eric Thomas,
people are going to hop on and hop off,
and you're not going to
really build as strong
a brand as you could
if you were consistent.
That's the entire point of
that video and this one too.
Kevin Barry, "I like this a lot.
"I want to have consistent uploading,
"but it's so difficult balancing quality
"and quantity.
"Keep this series going."
I hear you man.
I think it's just
constant experimentation.
I think again, the quantity
leads to the quality.
It's hard to produce
something that's really
if you've never done it before.
So the first time you try something,
it's going to suck, but then
maybe there's a seed there
that you can use to expand
on that will make it a little
bit better next time, a
little bit better next time,
little bit better next
time, and maybe you have one
series that just works really well,
and you keep doing that,
and then you experiment
by adding new ones every time.
For us, this Saturday time slot
is always a different video.
We're experimenting with
four to five different series
to see which one is a
hit, which one takes off,
that maybe we put into our
regular weekly schedule
instead of once a month,
and so having some way
to constantly test new series, new ideas,
a lot of them won't work,
but if you don't test,
you're always going to stay where you are.
You need that constant innovation,
constantly working on the
quantity to get to a point
where you're making quality
videos consistently.
The idea is to get them
both, quantity and quality.
The Universe Guru, "I do one
upload and one live chat a day.
"Do live chats count the same
way in the YouTube algorithm?"
That's a tough one.
I don't think they do
as much, to be honest.
I don't have a lot of data to back this up
like I do for this series,
it's just an intuition.
When you go live, you
get an immediate hit.
YouTube will email out a
lot of your subscribers.
They'll promote it across all your videos.
So you should get all of
these people coming on
to join you live.
I feel like the live stuff
dies down afterwards though.
I don't know, I feel like
it doesn't get as much
promotion, doesn't get as much benefit.
It may just be because in a live video,
there's a lot of dead time,
and then people aren't as
engaged in watching the replay.
Maybe that's it, maybe that's why
they just don't do as well.
You want to eliminate as much
fat as possible in the video
and make every second count,
and in the live videos, a
lot of fun stuff that's great
when you're on live, but for
somebody watching the replay
who wasn't part of the live
audience, it's not as much fun.
So maybe they disconnect.
So I don't know if it's a
purposeful thing that YouTube
doesn't promote the live
stuff as well afterwards
or if it's just that the
live videos are less engaging
for a non-live audience, and
so it ends up being downright,
but I have definitely
seen that connection where
my live videos don't do as well ongoing
as my regular videos do.
Alykia, "Oh my gosh, so many
videos, I'll never watch
"them all, ha ha."
That's great.
I made this great video
a while ago about how
I don't want you to watch
every video on my channel.
I don't, I don't need you to watch
I'd rather that you're out producing.
Watch something when you
need it, get inspired by it,
and then take some action.
The point of the multiple
videos per day is really
to just highlight what's happening with
the YouTube algorithm
and if you want to win,
you have to be consistent.
I don't expect people to
watch every single video,
and if you watch the people
who are going and making
mass content like that,
quite often their views
per video will drop, but net, they win
because add them all up, their views,
their minutes watched, their subscribers,
they win, and so if you
start moving to this model
of one-a-day or multiple times per day,
don't expect people to watch every video.
Don't be hurt when people
don't watch the video.
They're watching on their time
and it's on you to provide
as much value as possible
so they want to tune in.
Next up, Hairdresser on Fire,
"Hi Evan, I'm about to start
"my own YouTube channel.
"I could use some of
your knowledge on how you
"make your videos, equipment
used, where you begin
"in coming up with your
material, what programs you use
"to edit your videos, what
inspires you when making
"your videos and what your thoughts are
"on how your videos look now compared to
"the first videos you created.
"Thank you."
Back to a previous comment,
if you're just starting
a YouTube channel, do not
get hung up on the gear.
So many people get hung up on the gear
and they won't start until
they have all the gear.
You need the microphone
and you need the camera,
and you need the lighting.
You need all this stuff,
it doesn't matter.
When I first started, it was me,
I would face a window so
you have natural light
on you and not behind
you, and then just go,
just start talking, share expertise.
Your name is Hairdresser on Fire,
so I'm assuming you're a
hairdresser and you want to
share your expertise around hairdressing.
That's what really needs to come out,
and you could film really
great videos off of your phone,
with a friend holding
it or you buy a tripod
and put it up there and
if you're close enough
to the phone, they have a good microphone,
that's enough to get started.
Much more important than the gear is you.
You could build an amazing
start by you providing
amazing value, showcasing
what's so important
about hairdressing.
I think in terms of picking topics,
you got to find something
that you actually care about,
like if you're a hairdresser
right now, you have a shop,
what's the biggest problem
that you're seeing right now?
What do people come in asking about?
What's the biggest
misconceptions out there
that you want to help people with?
With any business, the
entrepreneurs try to provide
value and help people.
I genuinely want to help you guys.
Why am I making this video,
I want to help you guys.
Anybody who's in business,
it's not just to make money,
if you want to have success,
it's to help your customers
solve important problems in their life.
So you want to help
people with their hair.
How are you going to do that?
What's your message?
What problems can you solve for them?
What questions can you answer for them?
One of the greatest ways to get started
as a thought leader is just think about
all of the questions that
you're currently getting
from your audience and then
turn those into videos.
That's how I started my channel,
a lot of the early videos
were me answering questions
of people who had emailed in questions
and instead of answering back on email,
I would make a YouTube video about it.
It was faster and it
could also potentially
reach a wider audience
than just the one person
who was I was responding to.
So I would just start.
Start, start, start,
start, start, start, start,
get better, practice, get better again,
keep practicing, be an
amazing on-camera talent,
and then you can worry about the gear,
and then you can worry
about the editing software,
and then you can worry about
the bells and whistles.
Too many people focus on the icing
and they have no cake underneath them.
Truth Speaks Group, "Question,
is it better to post
"on YouTube or Facebook or post on both?
"I noticed you don't post on Facebook."
Facebook is really a pay-to-play economy
and that's not part of my model.
There's two things that I
don't like about Facebook.
One is that if you're doing a brand page,
you have to pay to get your content out.
You'll have a core group of an audience
who'll watch everything,
but to win on Facebook's algorithm,
you need to pay.
They have a market.
People are willing to pay, and so,
that's how you win in Facebook.
That's how you understand their algorithm.
YouTube is different,
and so I'm hacking the YouTube algorithm
to build up my channel.
The other thing about Facebook
that I don't really like
is the content doesn't
really live forever.
I want the stuff that
I make to live forever.
I want the stuff that I
make to still be visible
six years down the road,
20 years down the road.
I want to show my son as he grows up.
I want to show my grandkids this video
that I'm making for you guys
and the heart and energy and passion
that Evan Carmichael had in 2017.
I want them to see that.
I want the stuff I make,
people are still watching
videos that I made five years ago or more.
I like that.
I want to feel like every piece of content
that I make is going to live forever,
has the ability to do
so, and Facebook sure,
you can go back.
The posts don't get deleted
like they would on SnapChat
but you don't really go
back on a Facebook post
from five years ago.
You don't go back on Facebook
posts from two days ago,
and so I don't like that rush.
So I think with Facebook,
if you had equal size
audiences on both, you'll
get more instant views
on Facebook, especially if
you do and you kind of boost
around it to your audience,
but you'll get way longer
term impact if you're on YouTube,
and so that's the game.
I don't care about hitting
everybody tomorrow,
but I want people to be changed.
I'm in this for the long run,
and so YouTube is a better place for me.
YL Mompreneurs, "Has this
been 100% organic growth
"or have you used sponsored
posts/ads in the mix as well?"
It's not 99.7% organic growth.
We've done some targeted ads
based around certain videos
to help give them a
little bit more exposure,
but from my experience in
every campaign that I've run,
you can get views from advertising,
but you can't get subscribers.
Subscribers don't convert a
lot from the views on videos,
at least from my experience
in every ad that I've run,
and so we don't make that a priority.
If there's one video that
we're just trying to get
some awareness that
helps with the branding,
something like that,
then we may run a couple
of campaigns, but in terms
of driving subscriber growth,
it's almost zero, which sucks
but if you do the work
on the organic side,
you make really good stuff,
the people want to share,
where they watch the
video, and they're like,
that was amazing, I'm going
to subscribe to the channel
and tell my friends about it,
then you can get the growth.
So almost 100% of my growth has been
just from organic and
doing things like this
of understanding the YouTube algorithm
to get as much exposure as possible.
Pump Iron is asking,
"Evan, I love your videos.
"My question is how do I
make money on YouTube?"
That may be a future video.
I don't know, we'll see if I
cover that on a standalone.
I've done this already
on my channel, besides,
I think the way to get started initially
if you're just starting up as a YouTuber,
you'll make a little bit of money off of
the AdSense that comes in.
The key though as you're making more money
will come when you have an audience
and people start paying attention to you.
So I started getting my first brand deals,
my first brand deal,
I think I had around 40,000 subscribers,
somewhere around there
where I started to get
on companies' radars where
they wanted to hire me
to do stuff, get involved
with me, send me products,
hire me for things and so
when you start to build
an audience, then you'll start
getting more opportunities.
I got my book deal mostly because
I have a YouTube audience.
I get offers to join
companies' Boards of Directors
because of my YouTube audience,
things that I never thought of.
I never started my YouTube
channel trying to get
brand deals or book deals
or joining companies' boards
or investing into businesses,
was never part of the plan,
but it happened because
I built an audience.
So there's a painful
point at the start where
you're doing it because,
and this is any business,
by the way, like when you're
starting, it's painful
to start, you're doing it
for the love and the joy.
There's no company where you just start
and you're instantly successful.
There's a lot of heartache
and pain and blood
and sweat and working on the
quantity to get to the quality
that then leads to you
having opportunities.
If you sell an offline
product, trying to dance salsa,
YouTube is not our main
focus but when we make
YouTube videos it helps
promote an offline business,
like looking at Eric Thomas
who became YouTube famous
and he turned that into
offline businesses,
offline revenue streams,
seminars and conferences
and speaking gigs and I don't
know if he does coaching,
apparel, books, turned it
into an offline business
and doesn't focus as much on YouTube.
So other people have passed
him on the YouTube front,
but it's okay for him because
he's making money elsewhere.
So there's a lot of different paths,
but at the start, if you haven't started,
you're just on your way,
I wouldn't even worry
about monetizing.
If just making money is your goal,
do something else 'cause
it's going to take
a long time to get there.
You got to do the videos
because you love them.
Kyle Dunn, "How important
is production quality
"of a video, like editing
music, transitions?"
Kind of talked about it.
It's important but, sorry,
Christina editing this video,
it's important, but it's you.
You could have the best
editing in the world,
but if your message sucks
and you suck on camera,
it's not going to save you.
You would get way better
results is you doing it.
So don't let those things hold you back.
Get started, improve your message,
get better, practice,
practice, practice, practice,
practice, make a good video.
Anthony Lazaro, "I think the
million-dollar question is
"how do you choose the topics
with Google Trends video?"
I don't use Google Trends.
I don't use Google Trends at all.
Most of the topics come from
what you guys are asking for.
So when I'm doing a Top 10,
when I'm doing Believe Live,
when I'm doing Mentor Me, they come from
what you guys have been asking for,
what's already popular on the channel.
Our Top 10s, for example,
we have 3,000-ish requests
for Top 10s to do.
We look at what the most popular ones are.
So, what are the names
that have been put up,
who's been mentioned the most,
and then we start looking,
can we get enough content on them.
Some, there's not enough
content, so we can't do it,
but that's how we pick it,
and the topics for other
videos are usually based on
what you guys are asking for
or this series, I wanted
to make a video on it.
Nobody said, hey, make
a video series on how
to get a million subscribers.
I just wanted to do it,
and so it's that combination,
what the audience is asking
for plus what I'm doing.
We don't look at Google Trends and say,
hey, what's happening right now
and let's try to just ride this wave out.
It's definitely a model,
and maybe that's a blind spot for us.
That's just not how we've
achieved our growth.
Alright, I think I'm going
to end it there guys.
Tons of questions came in.
There's still a lot more to get too,
but I'm seeing some repeat ones come in.
So, if you have a question
you want me to answer
in the next edition of this series,
leave it down in the comments below.
If you see questions that you like,
give them a thumbs up
so I'll see them first
when I'm making the video next time,
and if you want this series to continue,
leave it down below as well.
Thank you guys for the love.
Thank you for joining on my journey to hit
a million subscribers, and
hopefully as I teach you
in the process, you'll
get strategies to apply
to your own channel to help
you achieve your goals as well,
whether it's hitting a million, 100,000,
10,000, 1,000, 10 million!
Whatever your subscriber goal is,
hopefully this series is helping you.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Playster.
Thank you so much for
bringing up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and sharing it on Twitter,
really, really means a lot to me.
I hope you're enjoying it, reading it
and getting value from it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is!
Much love, I'll see you soon.